what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 19th of the month or
the 20th i'm sorry from the heart of
[__] new jersey the bro the
joint is brought to you by draftkings
listen
nba season is up nfl is up college
football is up the baseball play
playoffs are here you're hungry for a
win this week and i got one for you
draftking sportsbook has you covered new
customers can just bet five dollars on
any nfl team to win that game and if
they do you win 200 and free bets are
you [__] kidding me or what
basketball is back
college football is here baseball this
is your way to make a little go before
the [__] holidays
tonight what do you got you got the la
dodges against the braves tomorrow night
you got denver giving three and a half
to cleveland or cleveland giving three
and a half to denver in cleveland friday
night listen to this one here san jose
state versus unlv san jose is giving
five points are you kidding me then
saturday you got college football sunday
you got pro football and everything that
goes with it you got baseball this is
your part of the year where you could
make a [__] killing
download the draftking sports book app
right now
and if sportsbook isn't available in
your state yet draftkings won't leave
you empty-handed they have a tremendous
fantasy sports contest all day so
download the draftkings dallas
daily fantasy sports contest draftkings
is giving all new customers a free shot
at millions of dollars in total prizes
with their first deposit over on daily
fantasy so do me a favor download the
daily fantasy right now from draftkings
or download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code joey j-o-e-y bet five
dollars on any nfl game to win their
game
and win 203 bets listen you can bet a
dollar to bet a hit if a player is going
to get a hit and where it lands and you
get 203 bets if you bet baseball listen
draftkings will not leave you with your
[__] in your hand they're not [__]
around they're here for you to make some
[__] guitars this week if they win
you win so use promo code joey this week
at draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nfl and
major league baseball and ufc now here's
the stuff the lawyers make me say i'm
sorry you got to be 21 or older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only
colorado tennessee new customers only
minimum five dollar deposit and one
dollar wager required
one per customer did you hear me one per
customer this is how good this [__]
deal is restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
book for details now do you have a
gaming problem you got to take care of
it call 1-800 gambler but if you're
straight your head is right remember
with draftkings you don't bet over your
head you bet what you got so do me a
favor download the draftking sportsbook
app download the draftkings fantasy app
press and code joey and let's win some
[__] guitars here okay draftking
sportsbook the best
the joint is also brought to you by md
hearing aid i know a lot of you is a
[__] young you don't need a hearing
aid but you know what
guys like me need it i know a lot of
young guys i got i got a niece that
wears hearing aids you ever have trouble
hearing me i can't talk any [__]
ladder so you may need a goddamn hearing
aid for years i struggled i'm not deaf i
have a problem with my ears where if i'm
in a restaurant i can't hear you talking
all i can hear is the dishes slamming
and [__] so i had to try hearing aids
you're thinking but joy i don't want to
look like an old man you won't they have
a sleek desire that fits inside your ear
and it's invisible no one will know
their water resistance you can wear them
in the shower no problem they got
rechargeable battery lasts up to 30
hours no one's wife talks that [__]
much hearing aids can cost you you know
what mines cost me 2800 a piece
these are just 2.99 each are you [__]
kidding me or what and let me tell you
something they're better than my [__]
hearing aids these are waterproof
rechargeable batteries they simplify the
design and cut out the middleman the
best part is it's all direct to you no
doctors no prescription needed get a 45
day risk free trial and 100 money but
100 percent money back guarantee
t if you struggle with hearing loss at
all you better try md hearing aids out
right now listen to uncle joey these are
as good as preeming hearing aids and
they are you know what i have a trouble
listening to the tv in the living room
for some reason the way they bounce off
the walls
when i put on my vault
i tell you what tremendous with the md
hearing aid listen to your uncle joey
the best part is nobody will know you're
wearing them so do me a favor
reclaim your life from hearing loss
maybe you got a grandpa a grandma an
aunt that you want to surprise him the
deal i'm about to give you is gonna
[__] make you fall off your chair go
to mdhearingaid.com right now use promo
code joey and i'm gonna get you're gonna
get a buy one get one deal 2.99 each
offer plus they're throwing in a free
extra charging case that's 100 value
just for the listeners of the joint so
head over to
mdhearingaid.com
press and code joey if you want to talk
they got a number grab a pen
three
thirteen fifty five that's eight three
seven seven three
thirteen fifty five put a one in front
of that
because it's md hearing aid you're gonna
love this deal okay buy one get one 299
plus they throw in the free charging
case that's everything for 2.99 like i
told you i paid 5600 from my hearing
aids to insurance and these are a lot
better md hearing aid download
mbhearingaid.com right now and press and
code joey we're getting this party
started
i just gave you a sports betting hearing
aids to hear the game who's better than
uncle joey let's get this party started
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
wednesday the 19th of [__] october
it's moving right along me and mike were
just saying what the [__] ever since
july
the [__] summer went right through
now i just remember it being october 1st
and it's
the [__] 20th already so
you i hope you [__] are making
things happen me time is moving fast
look at my hair i was looking at it last
night i'm pretty much bald from here to
here i just got a little bit of hair
that enough that i could it's like a
glove it's like a skunk tail like i just
put the skunk tail over here and it
covers pretty soon i'm going to be
missing this whole patch of my [__]
head too it's uh it really is [__]
crazy how i used to have a big [__]
jew fro
now i got nothing now i got four hairs
keeping it all together who gives a [__]
my hair served me when i needed it you
know what i'm saying when it's tough to
get your dick sucked when you're balding
22 especially if you got the grandpa
looking hairdo like the sides that's why
everybody shaves it because you just
look like a [__] fool if you have the
remember like and you know the little
bald circle with the hairdo over here
[__] all that [__] you know what i'm
saying what the [__] happened to my boy
the stones no more brown sugar when does
this [__]
[__] end
when does this end brown sugar
the song is i don't know 40 50 years old
right the stone's been around 50 i don't
i don't [__] know i know that
aerosmith celebrating their 50th
anniversary next year with a big concert
up at the [__] fenway stadium you
know who knows but the stones got to be
up there for how many years they got to
be together and i don't know how old
brown sugar is but brown sugar really we
can't play brown sugar no more
this is communism that listen
the biggest thing i took out of my
meeting the first time i met my cousins
that i really got to talk with them was
maybe 10 years ago
i was driving
one day and i got a call from uh
the manager at the improv and she said
to me that my cousins went from cuba
visiting and they saw my name and they
wanted to stop by so that night i
invited them to the store and uh i just
retweeted that my
cousin
emmy alfonso is singing at the grammys
or grammy.com my music is on there she
sent me a note the other day on twitter
but the one thing i took the most
out of their meeting then i went to
kantors kant this is like a jewish deli
on fairfax and la [__]
a little i'm more of a language type guy
but langes wasn't that i mean uh canthus
wasn't bad it was great especially when
you went there two in the [__]
morning
so i was in there with them and they
were telling me all these things about
cuba that when you get on a raft and you
come over they throw eggs at your house
they drive by your house and throw eggs
and all this [__] but they were also
telling me we started talking about
music you know i'm a music guy
and they were saying that you know they
had the led zeppelin's album with
stairway to heaven on it that was their
favorite album mine too and they
couldn't put it in the house i guess
they she was telling me she had the
cassette
and a couple
what it was was cassettes i don't mean
to be [__] wrong here they took the
cassettes and they had to bury him
outside not even on your property
you got to bury them outside of the
props let's say your tree went up to
let's say your property went up to a
tree you had a buried outside that tree
so they could blame it on anybody else
but a [__] led zeppelin now
a led zeppelin album
beetle music and then years later yeah
fidel was a big fan of john lennon
so he allowed john lennon to
they put the statue up but they weren't
big music in the [__] 70s you weren't
allowed to listen to nothing
american now they have you know rap
music and they have you know heavy metal
and they have all these groups uh
what's his name rudy sagel sent me some
videos of the heavy metal bands they had
in cuba
holy [__]
these guys are thrash metal [__]
making it happen
but in the 70s 80s 90s you weren't
allowed to play [__] music in cuba
especially anything [__] american so
what the stones got a call from somebody
one day and said they had to stop
playing brown sugar and they did it i
don't think mick jagger is a [__] a
sheep
but for him to say they're not gonna
play brown sugar anymore i mean it's
just i know keith richards said that he
doesn't see what the problem is with the
song and neither do i it's a [__]
song
i could see if it was two live crew you
know sitting at home with my dick em
heart i got a black book for a freak to
call all that [__] i get it there's
people in the room but that's brown
sugar there's no curse words there's
nothing but if they banned that that
made me [__] think that's gotta open
up my eyes and go
what the [__] is next
so anything now i'm pro [__] words
man i'm pro words we're not here to be
silenced we're not here to [__]
enough is enough already i'll be a
little bit crazy on this [__]
too we have to be we have to be because
this is this movement cannot work
silence silencing people you're not
going to tell me what material i can and
can't do we spoke about it on [__]
monday but this is actually going to be
a grown problem so now i'm [__]
jumping on this [__]
today i had a a guest on here that's uh
he's a great dude man i don't know
how to describe sam sam is a kid i saw
at the store
when he first got there one of the
funniest things
he was in the main room one night and he
i don't think he knew it
it was like a you know it was an older
crowd for some reason
and sam's up there doing ecstasy jokes
and chinese jokes and they're just
and i'll never do i could live to be a
hundred these are the things you learn
when you're up at the store what
material to do you know he did he
couldn't see him it's dark out he's up
there talking about doing a hit ecstasy
and [__] eating lollipops and
drinking water and twenty dollars and
they're just looking at him like we
don't know what the [__] he's talking
about i loved it you know i saw him go
through
what he went through the same thing i
went through substance abuse all those
years
you know the store was uh you know
years ago when they had a football
player that was a little [__] up they
sent them to miami why
if the guys already got a problem you're
going to send them to miami that's the
way it was with us i mean we had
problems and they sent you to the store
where you could do anything at the
[__] store you know i'm never listen
i'm never
gonna
tell you that i did bad things at the
store i didn't
it was what was there it was what the
night called for it was what what went
on down there for people to look and go
the store was a segway listen
women went down there looking for [__]
guys went down there looking for [__]
and they found that the drugs was a
different level
you know uh what people were doing there
it was really an experience
it was 23 years of my life that
i'm [__] proud of i'm very [__]
proud to be a comedy star comic i'm very
proud to have that moniker that mitzi
made me i don't give a [__] about
quitting high school going to jail or
that all went away when i got into the
comedy store that was the honor
it put on me and i feel [__]
honorable i know for a fact i'm one of
the green berets of comedy and you can't
take that away from that's just the way
it is 23 years cannot be erased by some
[__] joke or some stupid [__] i will
keep going forward i don't give a [__]
that's why what's going on now with
telling people what they can say and
what they can't say it's not going to
float especially with us from the county
store it's not going to float because we
were trained a different way so please
understand me understand where i'm
[__] coming from and understand what
i endured all those years people telling
me that your standup's not gonna work
here you're too dirty or this and also
i'm at the store mitchie shaw's telling
me i don't give a [__] if you light your
[__] on fire so think of that and
that's who i grew and that's why i grew
as a man and as a [__] comic and
that's how i ended up the comic that i
am and listen i might not be
you know 10 netflix specials in and all
that [__] do you think i worry do you
think i stay up and i worry about that
what i think about is what i did
and how it was a [__] it could never
happen again a street guy like me doing
time going to l.a and saying you could
all suck my dick movies soap operas
[__] games i did it all and you can't
take that away from me
welcome sam tripley to the [__]
podcast i hope you enjoy this [__]
savage
[Music]
what's up sammy tripp there he is
the best looking guy in the biz you bad
[__] what's happening i miss you
surviving brother survive in advance
that's what we're doing what's surviving
you're running things out there trying
brother everybody left i got to hold it
down how are you my friend i'm great
dude i can't complain look at you i'm
you know it's dodger baseball they got
to make it happen the other night i'm
sitting here and i'm [__]
going through [__] late night
i'm trying to put you know trying to
write a little bit
just to see what i could whip up and i
was thinking of our nights
your tuesday night
best show in l.a that was showing the
world dude
that was just too [__] much on
tuesday nights
the massage girl
the reefer the [__]
it was just the pizzas
there was always pizzas money you
it was uh it's very hard to match it's
very that's never going to happen again
in our world no man i was talking to
calamba today i was like dude just think
about like we were kings bro
what that used to be how like the just
just the energy in the room and like
when we say it was like when i say it
was the greatest show in the world it
was literally the greatest show in the
world it was the number one showcase
show in the entire world it was sold out
main room two shows every other week
that's 370 tickets two shows packed out
everybody you know just practicing the
model of abundance giving it all away
and uh it was a blessing dude and it was
an honor to be a part of it
and uh
you rogan burr
christian segora
hummings chris all of them theo
all of it dude
uh amazing just amazing you know you're
not doing your show anymore i mean jim
florentine brought it to my attention he
goes i don't think he's doing at the
store anymore
i'm uh you know
things change and we're feeling we're
figuring it all out there's a couple of
things going on i'm waiting to
you know have the la comedy scene figure
out its path right now and you know
we've talked before
i'm just i've been in this game for 20
i'm 48 years old i started doing
stand-up at 22 years old it's a long
time in the game
and you're kind i'm just kind of
figuring out what the direction is and
all my boys are gone so it's hard to you
know it's like it's not just about money
but it's about performing with your
friends and having this amazing night
and celebrating our friendship and
comedy and all that stuff and so it's
not the same so we'll see what happens
that's what it really was
you know i would drink three espressos
before i went down there on tuesday
because i couldn't bomb like i couldn't
[__] bomb like there's no way you
can't bomb at a tripoli show i would i
would do two spots and i was hoping that
bomb in the original room
you know what i'm saying because i would
do your show and then run to the
original room
due to 10 o'clock and get the [__] out
of there so i was like if i'm gonna bomb
i'm gonna bomb in the original one you
don't want to bomb in that name
i'm gonna say this about you you were
our sam kennison when you
were towards the end man you were just
leaning into you and what you did and
you were unfollowable and everybody was
like this guy's doing it the best out
there so it's like you really hit it
like an amazing stride
and are you real you really were our
kennison at that point you were you were
just like something no one's ever seen
and it was like it was an energy that
could not be matched and you just
brought it dude every [__] time bro
every [__] time and you you were had
this amazing thing where you would just
get off right when time was up you never
ran it you didn't have to worry about
that you just got in bam like a
gentleman got out got it and you look
great bro i gotta be honest with you
last time i saw you you were getting
shot in the head on tv you look [__]
phenomenal brother
you're like you're glowing dude i feel
good i'm glowing you know everything's
working out the pieces are starting to
align a little bit
it had been a rough you know it's been
it's rough without you guys it was rough
i got to admit it i gotta come full
circle here it was rough
the first six months for me like i was
beating myself up
did i do the right thing did i not do
the right thing you know i knew i was
burnt out on comedy i'll tell you that
that's the i did it dude i get that i
would i really get that dude you know
you said you have been doing comedy
since you were 22 years old and
how old were you when you walked into
the comedy store you were a young man
trips 25 bro
25.
that's 23 years ago man i i listen i was
at the comedy store
longer than i lived with my parents when
i was born
i got out at 18. i was at the comedy
store for 23 years and i saw everything
i saw death
in its dead times what everybody calls
it's dark period to like the zenith that
got so big that we were just talking
about i saw it all man and i loved all
of it and i'll tell you something man
that dead time that everybody talks
about is being super dark it was the
purest comedy ever was yes it was i mean
people were going up on stage doing
comedy for the sake of comedy not like
you know worried about the industry was
there because there was no industry
there and nobody showed up and it wasn't
about anything you'd be lucky there were
nights dude i watched paul mooney do
stand up for two people one time in the
or two people 45 minutes super crush you
it was about learning yeah there's a lot
of blow and craziness going on but it
was about stand up because the inmates
ran the asylum and we were just going up
there and it was the purest comedy will
ever be i don't think you'll ever in the
history time will ever get purer comedy
than that it was not about anything
other than trying to work this act and
getting better and all those people that
were there you all these guys you me
all these people have like are national
headliners a lot of them have netflix
specials and it's just like they became
the who's who of not just comedy but
podcasting so it was a very magical time
but everything changes you know it's
just like that's kind of as you grow
older but you start to realize that it's
like there's a cycle to life man and you
gotta kind of know what part of the
cycle you're in and it just let it go
let it go let it go and if it's meant to
come back it's meant to come back
you know i never heard somebody describe
the dark ages of the store like that but
i gotta be honest with you we'll throw
it on the table right now
that dark age is how i learned to become
a comedian you're absolutely right it
was pure i remember talking to hari one
night
here we are doing your show the thing is
busy there's a hundred people outside
the comedy store on tuesday nights
there's a line for [__] rap battle
you know
we we went through that people bring i
remember i would walk back then the guys
from abx tablets justin god bless him he
would go joey where's your car outside
i'm putting something in your car you
don't even want me to carry it they
would put it in your [__] car for you
you'd go to go home and then you look
back and they'd be [__] a of edibles
you'd have bags of weed [__] genos
speedweed with those blunts
we would get down there it was just
amazing to see and it was great and i
[__] appreciate it but i remember
calling aaron ari the store was on fire
last night he's like ah you know hurry
up
it's too [__] commercial for me now
you know and i'm like wow
and now you brought that up about the
dark ages guys if you're at home
watching this [__] listen
when you're a comic you want to be seen
we were all young we were all young we
wanted to be seen agents managers
production companies you know who came
to the store
nobody nobody dick you had to go to the
laugh factory if you went to the laugh
factory in those days i'll tell you
something every time i went to the laugh
factory i came home with a card
when the comedy store was dark i was
telling mike the other day that i had a
showcase for
nacho whatever the [__] wrestling
movie
jack black went and set up a latino
night and he had all the big fat
mexicans and a big fat cuban
me rudy you know all the fat mexicans he
had us do 10 minutes
felipe and he checked this out and then
afterward i spoke to him that was the
laugh factory you know who came to the
comedy store to see you
nobody no managers i remember if you
went to a manager if a manager came up
to you and said oh we're interested in
signing you where can i see you perform
you'd say the comedy store 10 30 11
o'clock you'd go nah
we're not going there there's no parking
there's nothing to eat you don't take
care of us they don't know like gold she
would throw them out of there do you
remember she she [__] did uh
the night of a thousand guidos with don
marrera and
the last minute mitchy sure goes [__] it
no industry comps
and all those young comics were pissed
because they thought that if the
industry went their life was going to
change
and she was like no industry comes stay
like everybody else they got to pay like
everybody else and that was the end of
that then andrew dice clay showed up for
the italian night and him and dom had an
argument in the main room in front of
everybody
because he said you're not attacking
it they used to go at it down there
and he uh i mean like he because you
know there was a time
where uh it was a comics would do hours
on stage just hours people people have
no clue what that was like and i was
working a valet job dude and i'd have to
be there at my job at seven in the
morning man seven in the morning dude
and sometimes i didn't have a car my car
wouldn't work so i'd have to like
hitchhike or get a taxi and it was crazy
dude and like these guys would come in
and they would do like three four hours
on stage and i was just people and these
young comics are getting angry because
they didn't get their five minutes at
the beginning of the show and i'm like
man you don't even understand dude three
four hours on stage i would leave there
at three in the morning they have to go
to home and get to work at seven in the
morning i was balleting down the street
and like i would answer the door and
people like oh my god you were the guy
on stage you were so funny grab my bags
i got to get out of here i'm like ah man
welcome to life
but it was an amazing time dude nobody
cared about the store
no nobody everybody
laugh factory's jumping the the improv
was jumping you know the the comedy
always changes and one of the big
changes was uh dublin's dublins came in
it was this big comedy show was a
tuesday night and it was on um
at this giant irish bar that became this
miami nightclub that for 20 years now
this club has just been empty and
nothing's happening they say it's about
rent or or taxes someone owns tax on it
and they just haven't done anything with
it but it just sits there right quietly
but it was at the time it was dublins
and this was during the shaq and kobe
laker like [__] pinnacle it was crazy
on the sunset strip dude
and this was the first time where they
had allowed where all three of the
comedy club comics would come and
perform together because before that you
couldn't if you you were connoisseur you
preferred consort if you were lab factor
you performed at the lab factory and if
you were improv you performed at the
improv and if your name got on like if
you were a connoisseur comic and your
name was on at the improv people would
be who couldn't get spots were calling
in snitching on you trying to get your
spots man and this is the first time we
had all come together in this [__]
insane comedy night that kinda i thought
changed comedy and then every it was a
free-for-all but man the comedy store
was d-o-a dead on arrival but i wouldn't
have had it any other way because you
got to go through it to get to it ma'am
you got it's got i mean dude people saw
where sebastian was when he started he
had his personality but working it out
to where he is now that would never
happen
if he had to do it in front of pac
crowds every [__] night
that's a [__] great point
i still remember going to dublin and
having such a great time that you didn't
want to go to the store
and
so here was the deal
the store used to do african-american
night on tuesday nights
and they would you know the brothers
would be everywhere
i didn't it didn't bother me i performed
there what was the name of the of the
show
that joe taught me
uh there was mo better monday no better
than those days that's improv fat
tuesday fat tuesday fat tuesday was when
i got to l.a was the biggest
[__] night it was the sam tripoli
show yeah it was crazy that that's what
bruce willis saw
what's his name and put him in the fifth
dimension
that's where what's his name saw corey
chris tucker that's what guy tori
that's what my boy saw guy tori and put
him in american history x
that was real i still remember the i
used to telemarket at the comedy store
for ends mitchell
ends mitchell used to be a manager at
the store oh damn comedy union comedy
union me shame uh
tons of us would be upstairs
telemarketing 10 bucks an hour giving
away free tickets and [__]
with enz mitchell up there that [__]
store would be dead
we were giving away tickets and people
still wouldn't come to the [__]
comedy store
like you got a dollar so far back in the
day dude i remember when steve run as
easy was working the working the cash
register at the comedy store and i walk
in he's like and he'd be like dude
should i start looking for a new job i'm
like i don't know this is how dead the
comedy store was the la jolla comedy
store was keeping the hollywood comments
comedy store afloat that's how empty it
was and we couldn't start a show until
we had like at least like two people
we had to get it like and if nobody
showed up we would wait until two people
showed up and then you would have to go
up and that's you know i i pray that you
can bomb an anonymity dude like you just
work through your [__] darkness with
nobody watching that's why i always love
those end of those night spots because
like everyone would go and you could
just [__] lean into your craziness
man and i dude those those days will
never be come back you'll never see a
brand that big
be that low and just power through it
you know
you know i'm in the process of writing a
book
so every night i gotta make notes and
then i talk to the writer in the daytime
i'm not a writer like we talked on the
phone for like an hour a day
and i'm trying to write that chapter
right now
about
the struggle
that [__] comedy store how we were
loyal to nothing
we were loyal to nothing there was
nothing there
there was paul mooney there was eddie
griffin
there was joe rogan
and that's it the rest was us
you know every once in a while gary
chandling came in or
andrew or [__] sarah silverman or
something but that was it
that was it none of these names would
come in it would just be us learning
you know doing drugs
[__] around with women you know it
was just a grind and it was you're right
it was an asylum run by the inmates yeah
do you remember there was a manager he
said he had work like 80 days in a row
the white kid he ended up leaving like
he cracked mitzi cracked him he packed
his bags and [__] went back to
wherever state he was from and you every
once in a while he pops up on facebook
like behind the people like he didn't
want mitzi to find him he's like how you
doing joey if you come over here call me
and he puts the bleaker back it was just
crazy there used to be phones
i i still remember being a broke comic
and at night i would go into the
manager's office and go did anybody
bring back a phone i lost my phone i
didn't have a [__] i had a pager i
didn't even have money for a phone
and they would give me they would give
me the box and the manager would get up
and leave
and i would get the phones and then
bring them to the [__] guys that rob
banks down in uh in compton they were
friends of eddie griffin the kansas city
crew
you can't even write this [__] i mean it
was just i remember pulling up and the
beer would deliver the beer and the
booze and i go
i could rob these cases right [__]
now
now i was a sticky fingered thief and i
never robbed the store
like i would pull up at 12 and i would
see the cases of whiskey out
and i was like if i go back to stealing
i'll never be a comic like this will
just ruin my [__] dream
so i never touched nothing at the store
it wasn't until years later i'll tell
you i used to rob a waitress at the
store years later oh my god
she would put a tray by the thing and we
would come up to the tray and she would
leave the money out of the tray like
little if we took it for a 20 it would
be enough and she blamed somebody else
i'm not going to tell you who for years
she thought when i found out that she
was blaming a different comic now i went
down mondays to robber like every monday
i would go down there just to rob but
there's nothing at the store on monday
nights nothing even back then
but i would go down to the robber but
the best robbery i ever did at the store
and this was like i did like maybe six
heists at the store but the best one i
ever did was i go into the manager's
office to get a check and this white i i
still remember his face but i don't
remember his name robert maybe he had
the hair on the side like dick van dyke
he had the button shirt he was just out
of college he was really into this job
like he was using everything from his
degree for this job and the inmates are
running the asylum we don't even need
you here just open the back and get us a
[__] beer we don't need your
education here we didn't need it we you
needed a death mute he would have done
the job so i walk in and he's like hey
how can i help you i need to get see if
i have any checks back here because
sometimes even if you didn't have a
check you just looked
that's how big you were open bro that's
how broke you were that check was paying
rent and the improv used to leave the
checks out you don't know how many times
i robbed the drew carey check
for the small 750 or the you know
because they were like seven dollars and
fifty cents or fifteen dollars i would
just be
i would just paid seven dollars seven
dollars
i would be so desperate i'd take the 750
and go right to the cash check cash in
place on whitley and
hollywood boulevard they knew me by
first name and that [__] i would
be so broke i was stealing
seven 7.50
when i used to work at the store they so
i got picked up thanks to mazda brandi
major bonnie and duncan charleston got
me at the store i would work a full
shift bro we're talking seven eight
hours if eddie griffin comes in it could
go up to ten for
twenty-five dollars bro so it was the
whole pay for the shift was twenty-five
dollars that's all i got and she would
but she made me a regular
and she made me work the door and i was
blessed for that because i learned so
much but man they got away with murder
back in the day the comedy store didn't
give zero [__] there were no rules to
them they operated in their own thing
and that's kind of what they needed at
that time and times have changed dude
and things change we'll see what happens
i love everybody over there just letting
them figure out their path you know but
yeah man it was outlaw and that's why
what i find so far and for the longest
time dude
up until this crazy pandemic happened
the comedy store was this the mecca of
comedy and the mecca of comedy
podcasting all the biggest podcasts were
somehow associated with the comedy story
and we were also the center of the war
against political correctness and
political correct comedy it was a
cultural event going on at the comedy
store and i don't think anyone would
really appreciate it until like now when
a couple years later we realized like
what we were in the middle of we didn't
know it because we were in the middle of
the storm but later on we look back it's
like
this is the stuff the legends like when
they talk about the d martin and frank
sinatra like we were the comedy version
of that like people would always say all
the time it's like the comic store was
like nothing ever like you could go to
the whiskey right you i saw velvet
revolver at the whiskey right i never
got to see them in the hall and talk to
them you could have your favorite comic
just walk right past you in the hall and
engage you in five minute conversation
that doesn't happen anywhere else in
entertainment nowhere else there's no
other play even the comedy seller which
is like
like the comedy store version on the
east coast like comics sit up in a
certain place there's a there's a
there's a stairwell to where they go on
stage there's no real place that you get
get the hang out and just chop it up
with your favorite comic man it it is
truly the mecca of comedy and we'll see
what happens but
even if i never perform there again
whoever knows what will happen but let's
say i never performed there again i got
the comedy store in my blood it's in my
bones dude i bleed red and black man and
i i i i'll take the communist wherever
i'm performing man
but a lot of people don't understand
is that for a guy like me i got locked
up
i [__] uh got no high school diploma
i got a ged i quit high school
you have no idea how being a part of the
comedy store made you feel
like i can't explain how i feel like
people say to me well joey i can't
believe you're not doing comedy you
didn't know what i saw either
i saw a lot i saw a lot and not bad
things
i just saw
the belly of comedy
i just saw it already i was at the store
what he's talking about and we took it
as nothing what he's talking about that
it was the
the center for i remember going up to
mitch and going mitchy do you mind well
nothing
nothing was sacred in there whatever i
remember taking my dick out on stage
there
thousands of times and she would go
out the turtleneck again keep it in your
pants
it was what it was about she knew what
was going on there with sex and drugs
and rock and roll she knew she was
participating in she was the [__]
leader of it so
for us like what happened last week
three things happened last week that
were against my core
dave chappelle special john gruden
getting fired
for something he said 12 years ago
and
the stones no brown sugar that is pure
communism
i don't know how the [__] you're right
dude mcjuggernuggets cultural marxism
bro
that is pure communism like it's
you could smell cuba in the air i could
smell the bananas and [__] like that and
the sweaty people you're telling me
that's not what because it's about
slavery what what i don't even get all
this [__]
and who's complaining about the rolling
stones and a song they sang you know it
just makes no [__] sense but they
love
they love john they love john lennon do
you know a song that john lennon sung
on his on like the tonight show bro do
you want to hear the words he sung on a
tonight show and these are john lennon's
words women the [__] of the world yeah
that's it that's like you believe
that that's where that that is that time
brown sugar is from a time to erase it
doesn't change anything it doesn't make
the world any better everybody's worried
about brown sugar okay nobody's worried
about what's going on with in libya
which is open air slave drinks like
there's real [__] going down but no
one's gonna say anything about that
because obama caused it so it's like
this is this is a classic
textbook
cultural marxism which is completely
rewriting history and that's what we're
in into right now and this is why some
people are allowed to say something some
people are it's all part of cultural
marxism and it's all being pushed by
rich kids rich white kids and you have
malcolm x and you have the unabomber
both saying the same thing rich white
liberals are the most dangerous animals
in the world because they're pushing an
idealism that they don't live that
they've never lived through someone like
you from cuba your family you talk about
what happens when you get real communism
not theoretical socialism which is what
always happens it's that's where it
leads to and
it's just unbelievable that you have
these kids who are just like railing
against the patriarchy and all that you
know yeah that gala event where all
these people are like pegged the
patriarchy that woman that wore that
shirt her family are all
royals she's from they're they're the
patriarchy so you have rich kids trying
to get rich white kids trying to
convince everybody that poor white kids
are the problem when in reality the
patriarchy that they're rallying against
is is all their fathers and their
grandfathers have all done it and it's
what happens all the time they're super
young they rail ah man of system then
they get to a certain age and then he
just they walk right into their daddy's
office and they start doing everything
they hated so it's like yeah it's
bizarro [__] town right now but
people like you and rogan and what i'm
doing any legion of skanks they're right
there too like they're creating a system
in which young versions of us can thrive
enough i'm killing it right now you know
why because i deal in authenticity
brother and that's why you've always
resonated with people because you are
authentic as [__] and in this [__]
age of phony [__] truth like you're
talking about robbing waitresses all
that [__] they're dying for some realism
dude that's what people want and that's
why there'll always be a place for us
you know and now you're in this major
movie it's like
all the blessings in life
because you're such a good dude and
you're so real that people in this sea
of [__] you're a buoy brother you're a
lighthouse in this [__] sea of
[__] dude how can
we be
such a [__] [__] society
with like a [__] society now
like we're yelling at a kid for stand up
this happened
20 years ago with andrew dice clay
they weren't looking for his head they
weren't you know what i'm saying like
and they were in a way
you know when he went on sinai live and
said all that stuff but nobody was
looking to cancel him andrew went away
on his own people thought that they went
that oh well andrew no andrew went away
to raise his kids
you thought you put him down with your
stupid
[__] oh well we don't like dirty
comedy he went to raise his kids
and then when he finished raising his
kids he made a [__] comeback a killer
comeback i kill a [__] comeback he
just did the tour of his [__] life
yeah you know
and
now you want to take what chappelle did
and this guy got his feelings hurt well
it's time that this country toughened up
a little bit
that's the first thing your mom taught
you but sticks and stones will [__]
break your bones and words will never
hurt you
you're going
leading this charge is a is the is the
show runner for a show called dear white
people right there she's [__] on
another group which makes her a [__]
hypocrite now here's the bizarro part
she is a white trans woman okay
which means she was born a white man
transitioned into a white woman which
means she is white people she's all
white people
he's both sides of it and she's [__]
yelling about how bad white people are
and she's yelling at a guy for making
fun of her group when she openly makes
fun of another group imagine being a
black actor on the show dear white
people and you're getting notes from the
show runner who is a white trans person
on how you should be acting in this
blackness it is clown town they want to
try they want to cancel dave chappelle
okay for some jokes while they were all
fine with cuties which is 11 year olds
twerking right and you and i both have
daughters the the notion of that thing
happening is extremely frightening yet
these liberals most of them don't have
children and don't have skins in the
game act like jokes are the worst thing
in the world and i'll tell you why
because most of the people leading this
charge again are rich white kids and you
you study their life
joey they're born into [__] the best
hospitals right they go home to the best
houses that are behind the the best
gated communities they go to the best
schools right out the gate private
schools they graduate high school they
go to the most prestigious private
colleges they get interned right into
the best gigs they start going to the
best restaurants and the best clubs they
marry high elite people their life is
nothing but pampering okay so when they
say
violence is never the answer and mean
jokes suck it's because there's only two
things in the world that can affect them
that are words and violence and that's
why they're trying to [__] outlaw
everything because i've just said this
before the word these people want a
world that plays to their strengths and
outlaws their weaknesses okay
and that's what they're trying to create
right now words and violence are the
only thing that can affect super right
kids saying [__] giving them the truth
and then just punch them in the face
they can't handle any of that because
they've been pampered for so long so
that's why what political correctness is
and political correctness is truly
fascism and george carlin said the exact
same thing it's gonna be a different
kind of fascism it's not gonna be it's
gonna be where it's like one dictator we
got this what they call corporatocracy
is coming in and that is where
corporations are going to run everything
and that's what they're doing right now
and that's why dave chappelle is herald
by one side and i love dave but then
john gruden who hasn't nobody's seen
these emails by the way we've just told
what they're in they've never shown us
email this guy's demonized and steps
down loses his job it's all part of the
mind [__] that's going on right now
lose his job
and gets his
past glories taken down
they took him down from the ring he won
a [__] super bowl
his players would have complained about
him over the years we would have saw
players going gruden as a [__]
is a nazi gruden is a [__] slave
trader you know we would have seen
things there's nothing
he's brought an email about lips that
the guy was lying through those big lips
he called somebody a half a [__]
you know a good dollar and by the way
goodell has gay face
that's i mean the guy is gay fans i mean
the dude looks like he loves dick i've
been saying that for since he got the
gig i'm like that dude loves dick dog
and that's why
they hit so hard with him you can't go i
mean like what is punching up and
punching down i mean you're worried john
gruden i mean like goodell has been a
piece of [__] forever and now we're all
worried about his [__] feelings
i mean get the [__] out of here
get the and here's the problem joey it's
like what is the end result what is the
goal line of this whole thing like what
is equality what
and i have a lot of trans friends dude i
used to do a lot of drugs and just met a
lot of weird people okay i mean i'm
being honest with you that's just who i
am i shined in the darkness i have a lot
of weirdo friends i have trans friends
that walk in here and you're like that's
the hottest chick you've ever seen in
your life trans [__] person right i
know these people okay most of them
don't want to deal with all this
[__] they hate [__] drag queen
story hour they hate all this [__]
[__] but these really loud people that
and that's really always what it is man
it's a small group of people most people
just want to get get along and live
their [__] lives but you got these
squeaky wheels that caused all the chaos
and they get pushed to the front to get
us all the fight with each other but the
question is joey what is the goal line
equality well what is equality
what is equality let me tell you what
equality is the more you're in the more
[__] you [__] get it's not the more
you in the less they make fun of you the
more you in the more you get made fun of
that's how it goes look who gets [__]
all the time george bush uh donald trump
joe biden kanye west the kardashians
jesus christ we can go down a whole list
of people that are just the blunt of
every [__] joke because they're so
[__] in the morning the more [__] you
get so watch what you wish for this
notion that gay people don't do funny
[__] or black people don't do funny [__]
or women don't do funny [__] it's just
the most ludicrous thing in the world
black people are hilarious and i'm gonna
make observations about black people you
ever been a world star hip-hop dog just
seeing crackheads jumping off from third
floors doing belly flips it's like
[__] funny i can't talk about that
get the [__] out of here that's right
the video down with the black dude who
put the firecracker in his eye in his
[__] eye i love a brother who puts a
firecracker in his eye
you know and they look at people for the
wrong i was thinking about myself like i
got to be honest with you i say some
[__] up [__]
but at the end of the day i would put my
hand out to any race and i've done it i
know i've done it for a [__] fact
i've done it
you know i'll goof on arabs bro i have
three arabs that are my best friends
they call once a week the whole [__]
deal
i thank this was one particular kid that
i think about him once a week
because i couldn't get economics down
and he [__]
worked at me he would take me to lunch
and work with me on economics and i
finally got it down in college and i
always said that [__] regardless
but i'll say the craziest things about
black people chinese i'll say the
craziest things but i'll bump into
somebody who comes up to me who's
african-american
and i go hey man they'll come up to me
go ahead we like the podcast and at
first you go
you know you said some [__] on there you
know from time to time
and now and i asked him did you ever you
ever watched the podcast and feel like i
was racist they go nope
you just funny [__] you say it
how it is
but we could they feel it
they know who's racist and it's like me
when people talk about spanish people i
remember calling bobby i remember
getting a message from bobby slate one
day for christmas and he's like hey man
i just want to wish you a merry
christmas even though you're in a roach
and pestered tenement
in the bronx with a bunch of spicks
now somebody would have got mad i don't
get mad at any of that [__] but i will
tell you i could tell when somebody's
serious
and i could tell when somebody's just
making me a butt of a joke and i love
being the butt of a joke but
when somebody like you spit [__]
i get that when they're serious 100
and it's the difference between a a
racial uh joke a a racist joke and a
racial joke now i will even defend
people's right to say off colored stupid
jokes i mean it's okay we shouldn't be
canceling people people shouldn't be
losing their jobs when i write a joke
man like i have a joke about this one
female comic in la that's so hot but she
only bangs black guys right and i'm like
you're so [__] hot i'll paint my dick
blackface that's how hot you are okay
all right i'll put black paint on my
dick if it means getting some of that
ass okay but my question goes my
question goes could a black comic write
that joke and if the answer is yes i'm
writing the [__] joke because it's
not about dude equality isn't
segregation it isn't and that's the
biggest thing when you see my news
special right it's uh called no life's
ma i mean uh no lives matter
always the comment and it's 99 positive
and there'll always be a couple negative
comments and it's always the same thing
oh racial comedy it's so lazy right but
these political correct people
force everybody into these silos so when
i like the reason i have a big problem
with la comedy is now i know what
everybody's gonna talk about based on
what they look like oh black comics
gonna do white people do this white
people do that women are gonna talk
about their [__] mexicans are gonna
talk about
because societies these walk people folk
full
force everybody into these silos where
watch netflix specials everybody's just
doing their stereotypes there's nothing
original so it's like don't tell me i'm
lazy when you force everybody who who's
[__] getting specials to be super
[__] lazy dude i say talk about
everything like anthony jeselnik right
he's a good friend of mine he's got 50
minutes on kiddie porn
i hate that [__] but i'll defend his
right to do those [__] jokes to the
end of [__] days if we're playing
punching up and punching down there's no
more punching down than that subject but
i will defend anthony jeselnik's right
to do awful [__] jokes because and i
love anthony i think he's one of the
best comics out there but
i don't get that those jokes but that's
his right to do it
because
nothing should be off [__] the table
if you could do if you do a movie on a
subject okay you should be able to do a
joke on the subject and the problem is
the people who get offended think comedy
is about [__] patty cakes they think
it's meant to be yay and no dude comics
are some of the darkest [__] i
know and they talk about the [__] that
we really need to hear about and if you
can't handle it don't come to a comedy
club
you know i remember
when cat william said
you know and i
watched the special i knew kat before he
hit i did one of his rooms and he was
very fair to me
and that michael jackson joke that he
does that's one of the most brilliant
jokes of all time that's what broke him
if you listen to that joke
it's a 50 50 in the room
that means the room was split down the
middle
some people were owen
some people were like laughing but they
couldn't really laugh out loud because
the people next to them were owen
and to me
that's
what comedy is
yes dude yes that has always when i saw
it i go that's comedy
now we got to get a [__] who
could do that for 45 minutes straight
and chappelle hit it you know chappelle
fit that mold it wasn't me it wasn't you
it wasn't rogan it wasn't segura
it was chappelle you know and i and i'm
happy that he did it
but that's what it's supposed to be when
you go to a comedy show yeah you're
supposed to laugh a little bit but if
the comic's doing his job he's gonna
bring up a couple subjects
that should make you squirm a little bit
in your chair just a little bit i don't
want you to leave angry and you
shouldn't be getting angry
you should listen to it say
i'll never pay 20 bucks for this jerk
off again
and go on your merry way
not make a video
and put it on youtube and try to ruin
the [__] guy
you didn't like the joke wouldn't it be
doing it when did becoming offended
become a felony
when did that happen you're offended so
the [__] what man so what comedy's meant
to elicit a response and your response
is offended job done
wait there'll be another joke coming
that's it that's the same way i [__]
look at things too that's it you know
chappelle did his job
if you watch that special as a comic
and you got the balls to raise your hand
and and
the other uh go against chappelle you're
a [__] hypocrite and your comedy
sucks
because that's what you're supposed to
do
your world collides with the rest of the
world tell me about it
you don't like abc news tell me why and
i'll listen to you if you explain it
we're in don't just come up there and
say i hate abc news
but if you tell your take on why it rubs
against your world
that's what a joke is
you might not like it maybe you like abc
news that's why there's vanilla and
chocolate because not everybody likes
vanilla
and you have to accept that but for you
to try to ruin somebody's life
because they said something
that's basically the truth
people don't want to hear the truth you
know we heard it years ago with
that [__] movie with the the
scientologist and the chick that [__]
bruce willis
whatever that was you know
you don't go unclear was it called going
clear something like that no no was the
movie the army movie with jack nicholson
when
oh oh you can't handle the truth yeah
you good man the truth that goes that
resonates in our society
we can't even handle it's like if i came
up can i go sam can i talk to you for a
second comic the comic because this
happened to me
when i first started like five years
four years into comedy somebody tried to
come and give me
advice
but while he gave me the advice he told
me my negative
and i took offense to it
i left i listened to his advice but i
walked away and then i went back to beat
him up
when i got back he wasn't there
but then i went home and i thought about
the words he said to me and i go that
[__] wasn't insulting me he was
building me up
he was building me up he was telling me
what i needed to do to build up to be a
good comic and i listened to him
i got offended
just a little bit you know like just a
little bit like joe pesci you offended
him just a little bit with the [__]
uh whatever joke but
oh my [__] funny you think i'm funny
jimmy schubert did that to me one time i
kind of you know i'm a father-son dog
you know my dad
instilled a lot of things into me a lot
of positives some negatives you know one
was a little bit of paranoia and a big
ego uh because i think sometimes as a
comic you gotta be boxer almost you
gotta almost believe in yourself when
nobody else does even when you're having
some weird sets and
and brother i've had bombs i've had
i followed you there's three people at
the comedy store that i follow i bomb so
hard i question whether this is what i
should do for a living you lisa
lampanelli and i think the other one oh
was uh
what's his [__] name the the old guy
with the gray hair that's uh part of the
blue collar tour i forget what his name
is ron white
yeah yeah yeah yeah i bombed the rough
nights dog night rough night like these
are learning moments but jimmy schubert
took me pulled me aside on a gig one
time and he goes hey dude you're really
funny
but you man you got bad attitude you you
you just you just you're just rubbing
people the wrong way man
because you're going around acting like
you've done [__] and you haven't done
jack [__] you're super funny man people
want to like you but you're you're just
you're and i re that that resonated with
me because i felt like i'd said that
about my father at some point like he
just couldn't learn to work well with
others and like from that point on
even in recovery though i learned i
worked on that like nobody's thinking
about me man nobody's doing it i have to
listen
to what people are saying so you know
and sometimes the truth hurts like
dana just gave me a note on a joke
and like i kind of got mad but i
understand what she's saying
so i'm gonna like twerk the tweak the
joke a little bit you know so it's like
you have to when you when you get a past
being open to criticism that's when i
think you start to be in a little bit of
decline you start to lose the plot and
the narrative and the respect for your
crowd i think you always have to have a
tiny bit of healthy fear
of the audience and that
you hope that they love you because the
minute you don't care i see it happen
all the time there becomes a disconnect
between you and the crowd if you don't
have a healthy
desire for them to like you
and want to apprec and do something that
they'll appreciate i think you lose the
plot of stand up
kind of respect the audience you got to
think about them
think about their every feeling i think
you know for me to become a great comic
i had to stop thinking i had to start
thinking about the audience
and yes that fear
is healthy
because once that fear is gone you
shouldn't be doing it
my good healthy fear is gone i get a
little fear from doing the podcast
when mike
i know he's on his way up here
for like 10 minutes before mike comes
here i got to sit down
because you get a little scared yeah so
sometimes i go maybe i should just
cancel no yeah
this is what is natural
i don't know how many nights you know
especially going to the [__] store
you know doing i don't know what's
scarier
doing uh a road gig and trying to be
you know a great comic for that audience
you know what they went through and they
paid or
going down to the store
when you're only going to do 15 minutes
but you're gonna be
with the [__]
with the people who matter you can't go
down and fail
can't go down here fail you're gonna be
with bill burr and this is your chance
to earn your [__] you know to earn
your [__] wings
you gotta [__] earn it every night
and this is it never mind going and
doing red rocks
in front of eighteen thousand people
yeah
in life that breathing oxygen
go down that [__] store on a tuesday
and go in that [__] jungle fest that
they have your show the original there
was a there was a part i would look at
that lineup before i went down there
every tuesday and i had to stop
like i'm just going down
once they call you and tell you have a
spot don't look at the lineup because
that's going to affect your game 100
100 if you look at allie wong
crystalia ron white and then i'm
somewhere in there it's going to affect
you don't even look at the lineup just
go down there like you're eating ass
with your head pumped in
straight [__]
you're going right with the third eye
right there
i'm totally with you man it's such a
psychological game that's getting played
because if you you really get great at
comedy you become like a cult leader you
just get the whole room
thinking as one you get all these
strangers to think as one moving group
and it's like that's why when you [__] a
joke up people snap out you gotta put
them back into the into the thing so big
trance so a big thing for me man was
like i realized like because i lo you
know tom road says i i do stand up like
i'm playing at the front of the net in
tennis right the really aggressive john
mcenroe type [__] style right which
is totally true because i do get off on
seeing what i can get away with but one
thing i really learned is like i can't
just be doing that the whole time
i have to stick and move so it's like my
whole thing is like
i my style of comedy joey i call it
gator roll right i call it the gator
roll and what the gator roll is is i
grab them at the top like an alligator
does and i slowly slowly drag them in to
the deep dark waters of what i find is
crazy and that's where i get them right
but i can't open crazy i can't i used to
open crazy embarrass and just
just bury myself and it's just like you
can't do it it's a psychological
operation you have to start very very
slow and easy with relatable [__] like
now i got all these jokes about my kids
right now like real simple but they're
sam tripoli jokes so it's really simple
stuff and then by the end i'm talking
about how like
days are days are like mass nazis now
like they [__] like if your nostrils
come out like you're flying the [__]
gay stewardess will be on you but i'm
like these are the ones who could this
is a demographic that couldn't like stop
[__] each other during aids like
you know i mean so it's like this and
then they're laughing at it because i've
taken this time to [__]
psychologically bring them and prepare
them into what we're doing it's very
psychological man stand up that's why it
takes 10 years
just to truly get to where to understand
it to master it takes another five to
ten on top of that and that's why when
like the comic walks in you see kill you
like how long you've been doing it 20
years you're like yeah that's 20 years
of being in the lab working on
experiments and coming to understanding
what [__] this this jedi mind trick
[__] you're doing comics or jedi's real
great ones are jedis man
that 20-year mark really opens up your
brain i you know who told me that mitchy
sure paul rodriguez was on stage one
night in the main room
i went back there she was there in her
little booth and she
sat me in come sit down
and she said do you see what are you
doing that's 20 years and i remember at
the time i was doing comedy like 9 or 10
and i was like
check
you know what i'm saying check
we're going for the 20-year mark to do
what the [__] he's doing and it really
is you do really
it's a sight you know listen this is the
best way i can explain it from zero to
10 years
you can't call your shots you don't know
if you're gonna bomb it's a 50 50
in your head all i know is from 20 to 30
you're gonna bomb
but i have a little bit more control
over them and i know how to get myself
it's like
zero to ten years in jiu jitsu i got to
start on my knees after 20 years i'll
start on my back because i know i could
get the [__] out of there you know what
i'm saying yeah for sure dude
it's like what is the game plan what's
gonna work with this crowd
and
you know for me like i get off stage now
people like oh dude i really relate to
that stuff i never used to get that
because i've done it all like i bring
these young guys on the road with me and
there's sometimes i'm like i think these
guys are getting bigger laughs because
they're going for credibility right now
right they're trying to get credibility
with the crowd when i'm trying
to find out who i am as a person and if
any [__] can understand what
i'm talking about like 47 becoming a dad
used to have a bad drug problem
super sex addiction all these things and
now i'm in charge of two little girls
and like me trying to be
the best man i can for not my just
myself but for them like i don't want to
embarrass these two people and i'm doing
the best that i can like there's a
relatability to that i'm not going to
say the name of the kang but there's a
comic out there that used to be
supernova and i hear now he's kind of
struggling
and i think
it's because he hasn't
graduated to that next level of his life
personally
like a lot of the jokes that he's doing
are from you know when we were all
running the gun and hanging and banging
right
and now his crowd is much older they all
have kids they're all married with kids
that's what they want that's their
mindset and if you can't you know you
can't keep doing the same act the only
constant in the universe has changed if
you're not adapting and changing with
the times like for me to go up there and
just do the same act that i did as a kid
you know it would just
just completely fail on stage because
that's not who i am right now the truth
is that like i'm not a sexual dynamo
anymore i'd rather go to bed okay
i used to do a ton of drugs after this
show i'm going right back to the hotel
grabbing the hamburger and doing nothing
i'm like you caught me at the i have all
this power now and i don't want anything
to do with it i just want to go to bed
and wake up sober in the morning pray
write down my goals do my yoga do all
the stuff that like 10 years ago i would
be like laughing at this guy but that's
who i am now and it resonates with
people because
you know i mean you know just all the
craziness you used to do with people and
all the craziness you do with women and
now you see them on facebook they're
like i got free kids you're like used to
be a [__] savage it's growth man and
if you don't grow and your act doesn't
grow with you your job isn't to get the
[__] 20 year olds anymore your job is
to get the people who relate to you and
they're probably around your age
demographic if you get some 20 year olds
in there who appreciate what you talk
then that's great too but to be like
running and gunning and trying to get
these 22 euro you know i like it's it's
to be in your late 40s early 50 and
still be doing pop comedy i think you've
lost it
you got to really get honest and that's
why again authenticity is the key to
growth in comedy and entertainment
people want to connect with you with
real [__] they want to be like that's
some real [__] that guy just dropped on
stage and i think that's why you
resonate with everybody and when you do
want to go back
to doing stand-up if that day ever comes
people are going to be just thirsty to
hear what coco has to say and because
you always give the real [__] and that's
why it was always so hard to follow you
because it's like is my sh i mean dude i
used to the one of the biggest bombs i
ever had was following you at a joe
rogan show in san san jose you did
literally 10 to 15 minutes on ass eating
and i had to ask myself do i have
anything that could touch that and
according to the crowd there was nothing
i go i i had to follow joey diaz at a
joe rogan concert that's like middling
for van halen and the opening act is
david lee roth it's gonna be a rough set
dog you know but that's because you got
this authenticity way earlier than a lot
of us got it now to my best my ability i
live in that
and you know i think that's why i'm
resonating with people right now
you're doing a great i remember going to
see you when you had that
show with the chicks on stage and the
whole [__] thing
and you were up on stage and i walked in
it was at the improv ari was there and i
remember going ari was in awe like he
was just standing like typical ari you
know how he stands like that like
you know and i walked in he was just
watching and he was giggling
and i go what's up man he goes it's
great to see tripoli
doing tripoli
like look at this there's women and
playboy and [__] this guy and
it was great dude
it's uh it's been an education sam i
miss you i'm happy dude i love you so
much brother i mean like when you left i
cried and i still and sad about it but
seeing how you
seeing you right now talking with you
right now and just seeing like you're
glowing dude i couldn't be happier from
you and it's like sometimes you gotta
let you go to grow in life and that
seems what's happened to you and you
know i haven't been able to see you
since all this chaos but i know one day
we're gonna pow out together hug talk
mad [__] and
and love each other and you know i mean
like i love you to pieces i'm so happy
your movie rocked you were [__] great
in it uh i didn't enjoy watching you get
shot that kind of [__] me up but
outside of that it was a [__] great
experience you know i love you man i
know i'm a little crazy you know with
the conspiracy stuff but some people
don't call me anymore and they don't
talk to me anymore everything i do is
out love but you never left me and i'm
always appreciative of you and uh if
anyone's listening to me come see me in
miami this weekend all right go see him
where you at the improv i'm at the dude
i gotta go to miami i just want to go to
south beach and see how many chicks i
recognize from [__] bang bus you know
so that's where i'm going
it's always a [__] pleasure to go to
miami you see some [__] that you go get
paid to do it is like
at the end of the day we're living
pretty nice dude last time i went to
miami was thanksgiving weekend 2019
and i saw a girl there
at the improv that i had like this is
what you're talking about i had to take
a double look
in
1999 to bring new years in
they were at the improv in coconut grove
these girls it was her and another chick
with gigantic tits
and i had my girlfriend with me at the
time not my wife i had a different
girlfriend this is
98.99 and
we start talking and my girlfriend was
one of these [__] strippers who would
talk to other women that had big tits
and they you know she'd attract these
[__] lunatics and
you know all sudden my girls like listen
they're coming back with us
you know i'm in the [__] now we go
back to the hotel
and we're in the little [__] room
there and
i don't know these two girls are talking
now i'm concerned with my girlfriend i
really don't care about the two i'm not
gonna do nothing to them so i don't what
do i care my girlfriend's here you know
i'm saying but it didn't turn out that
way
next thing you know we're doing blow i
go to the bathroom i come on the two
chicks with the big tits are eating each
other out 69 and and my girlfriend's
there with a whip and i'm like what the
[__] is this
and she's like suck his dick and i'm
like you know
and the chick was handling they both
passed out and then the next morning we
had to wake up and they're on the floor
naked and when they saw me they were
like covering themselves i don't even
remember you from last night
i saw that crazy [__] when i went the
last time so that's what you're talking
about these crazy [__] that were
crazy 20 years ago and now they show up
with their moms
they got a wagon now with two car seats
and a [__] and an art thing in the
back so they could paint at the park
whatever the [__] it is so
yeah and when i saw we both locked eyes
and we're like and the last time before
that
i went to miami
this is in 2014 i went and the improv
was closed for a while
so they were still doing shows like a
burger place big room pretty cool and
the last night there i'm walking off and
i see this girl
she comes up to me
she goes how are you
good good you know i just thought it was
a general how are you like just some
lady saying how are you when i looked at
her
i kind of remembered her like a face but
she had gotten big like she had gained
like 50 pounds over the years
and i go how do i know you and she goes
we had a threesome in 1998 and i'm like
oh i remember that one heard a chubby
chick
and the chubby chick was [__] you
know you can't touch it she's huge and
i'm all coked up and the chubby chicks
like come in come in so i had to go
through her first and i just wanted to
start i didn't want to do the chubby
check so i waited till the chubby chick
left i played like sick i don't feel
good and the chubby chick wasn't at the
door and i was on top of the blonde and
while i'm on top of the blonde the
chubby chick comes back because she
forgot her [__] cup or cheeseburger
and she's like
what's going on in here i thought you
were sick i got to check out i'm 69 in
them i got the cape on and [__] and
she's like you just didn't want to be
with me i wanted to be with you i'm like
listen i was sick while you is i [__]
you
and she ran out of there and i ended up
with the blonde chick for a week until i
left and the blonde chick took me out to
dinner and said lose my number i'm
getting married next month
oh dude these shows
300 pound chicks
eat my feet
that was one of the
the weirdest threesomes i've ever had
they're like we just want to lick your
feet
i'm like are you going to throw some
[__] blue cheese on that [__] too you
[__]
[__] did they say who am i the judge
i'm a [__] thick monkey right now too
so love to all the big ladies out there
you know that's right god bless you i
think big chicks have tighter vaginas
anyways yes
[__] pringle cans for [__]
chubby chicks do have type bushies
because they just get [__] nobody
wants them lurking
you got to go in that ass with a crowbar
you know what i'm saying you ain't got a
crowbar you're going to bust that
muffler you can't bust the ceiling you
gotta get in there it's hot in there
i love your sam trips
you're the best ever do it i love you to
pieces and that is special someday soon
we can see each other in person i'll see
you at the gojo one is a special coming
up
the special's out just go to
samtripoli.com
all three of my specials are there the
two specials i shot at the viper room
and my brand new i'm not like this is
literally the only show i've ever
promoted i just want people to find it
it's called no lives matter and uh we
just light everybody up and it's a great
hour and i'm very proud of it so if you
want to watch a great hour it's about 38
minutes or you want to watch a 38 minute
special go check it out sam tripps i was
there when you walked into that [__]
store when you were 20 whatever the [__]
you were so
it's been a pleasure to see you grow up
into a man i love it how the girls
the girls are bad
blessed i'm just i can't believe i'm a
girl dad to two two two girls two little
girls know me as dad and that like is
such uh it's such a blessing and it's
like you know it's hard to go on the
road now man because i'd rather be at
home with them so i pick my times go on
the road and i take raising them very
personal i want to be the best dad and i
just want to raise
ninjas which by the way my daughter's
names are ghost and ninja tripoli so it
is what it is brother
tripps i love you i'll be in touch stay
black say hello to eddie thanks for
having me on buddy i love yourself
i missed you
love you
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed sam tripoli he's one of my
best [__] buds and uh
he ended up becoming
a [__] savage and that's what when we
walked in that store
that's what we wanted
to come out of savage you know you go in
one door you come out the back door and
you're ready for podcasts movies tv
shows arenas whatever they put on you
that's what the comedy store preps you
for
uh i love you [__] thank you
very much
for watching today and listening
whatever the [__] you're doing maybe you
download it maybe you're watching on
youtube as long as you [__] have your
ideas in your heart i don't give a [__]
how you put it in there stay black have
a great weekend laughing gas is on fire
me and mike were just talking about it
that's it and that's that have a great
weekend now for a word for my
[__] sponsor jack
all right we're back here i want to
thank my brother mr sam tripley for
coming on and dropping some tremendous
knowledge and i want to thank you guys
for always supporting the podcast before
i leave
a little word from our sponsors from the
heart of new jersey the joint is brought
to you by draftkings listen
draftking sportsbook is the best that's
all i could say
they're the official
sports betting partner of major league
baseball ufc
and the nfl you know they're reliable
they pay
they're there they got tremendous lines
they got a social network on there i
mean that tremendous draftking sports
book has you covered new customers this
week if you're hungry for a foot nfl win
you bet five hours on the nfl team to
win that game if they do
you win 200 dollars in free bets
winning winning winning this is what i'm
[__] talking about whether you're
doing basketball college basketball
baseball playoff sportsbook draftking
sports book has you covered now if
sportsbook isn't
available in your state yet or they're
not legal draftkings will not leave you
empty-handed everyone can play for huge
cash prizes all season long with
draftkings daily fantasy sports contest
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at millions of dollars in
total prizes with their first deposit
they're safe they're reliable they're
convenient and they're trustworthy
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey bet 5 hours on
any nfl team and if they win that game
you get 200
and free bets you can't beat that with a
stick
now do me a favor use promo code joey
this week at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl remember if draftkings wins you win
if they win you win if you win they win
now here's the stuff the lawyers make
you say you got to be 21 older new
jersey indiana
pennsylvania only tennessee colorado new
customers only minimum 5 deposit and a
dollar wager required listen to me very
important
one per customer don't be cute
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem you got to take care of
it
call 1-800 gambler
but if you're tight draftkings listen is
the best because you can't bet over your
head
but do me a favor to get this party
started you gotta download the draftking
sports book or download the daily
fantasy app right now press and code
joey and it's time to win some getus
the joint is also brought to you by md
hearing aids
listen if you got problems hearing me
you need a [__] hearing aid i
suffered with it from years i couldn't
hear the right thing i couldn't hear
people talking but you're thinking joey
i don't want to look like an old man you
won't
the sleek design on the md hearing aid
is beautiful and it fits inside your ear
nearly invisible no one will even know
you're wearing it they're water
resistant you could wear them in the
shower no problem plus they got a
rechargeable battery last up to 30 hours
nobody talks that much not even your
[__] wife hearing aids can cost
thousands of dollars like i told you i
paid 20 800 for mine
but these are just
299 each
how they simplify the design and they
cut out the middleman the best part is
this is all direct to you no doctors no
prescription you got a 45 day risk free
trial and 100 money back guarantee you
got nothing to lose
this is listen i know you're young
you're like joey you're insulting me no
you have an aunt you have an uncle you
have parents you have grandparents
if they struggle with hearing loss at
all you better try md hearing aids
listen to your uncle joey they're just
as good as premium hearing aids i can't
believe i overpaid until now and the
best part is
nobody knows you're wearing them so
reclaim your hearing
go to
mdhearingaid.com use promo code joey to
get there buy one
get one deal for 299 each
plus they're throwing in a free extra
charging case that's a hundred dollar
value where you gonna get that at come
on
this is just for the listeners of the
joints so head over to md
mdhearingaid.com
pressing code joey but if you want to
talk listen to this you can even call
them at 1-800-833-773-1355
it's time for the md hearing aid go get
yourself a pair i want to thank
draftkings
i want to thank md hearing aids
i want to thank better help and i want
to thank cbd lion for always having our
back but most importantly i want to
thank you guys for always having our
back thank you
for listening to the joint thanks for
sam tripoli and i love you [__]
with all my heart i'll see you guys
monday morning 8 a.m 7 a.m tip top
[__] magoo stay black i love
you
[Music]
so
you